هدوء ماكر ومعهود استدرج وجذب الاف
اليائسين فهناك على الجهه الاخرى امال
باحلام مفقوده وحياه بنظرهم لم تبدا بعد
غير ان امواج البحر الابيض المتوسط خذلتهم
حينما وبعثرتهم احيانا مقبره مفتوحه على
مدى سنوات ابتلعت المهاجرين واحلامهم
ليصبحوهم المفقودين
مئات حوادث الغرق المميته سجلت خلال رحلته
هجره غير مشروعه عبر المتوسط للراغبين
بالوصول للجانب الاوروبي منظمات امميه
احصت مقتل اكثر من 26 الف شخص منذ عام
2014 بينهم نحو 20 الفا على طول طريق وسط
المتوسط يوصف باكثر طرق الهجره فتكا في
العالم الطريق نفسه شهد وفاه 411 مهاجرا
في الربع الاول من هذا العام فقط من جعله
الاكثر تسجيلا للوفيات منذ سته اعوام
لا يمكننا الانخراط بنقاش اخر حول من هو
المسؤول فحياه البشر على المحك
قوارب غرقت واخرى حيدت ركابها عن النهايه
المبكره حيث عبر نحو 330 الف شخص بشكل غير
قانوني عبر جميع الطرق العام الماضي وفق
وكاله الحدود الاوروبيه وهو اعلى رقما
مسجل منذ عام 2016 مضيفه ان عدد من سعوا
للوصول الى التكتل عبر البحر المتوسط في
الاشهر الثلاثه الاولى من العام الحالي
زاد بثلاثه اضعاف عن سابقه لا سيما الى
ايطاليا التي اعلنت حاله الطوارئ بعد
التدفق الهائل للمهاجرين
مقصدهم واضح اما نقطه انطلاقهم فحددتها
شهاده عمال الانقاذ بتونس التي حلت مكان
ليبيا كمنطلق رئيسي للفرينه من الفقر
والصراعات في افريقيا والشرق الاوسط لكن
هؤلاء ياتون اساسا من ساحل العاج وغينيا
وبنغلاديش وتونس وباكستان
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات